اهلا بكم
باخمت من مدينه تنبض بالحياه الى مدينه
اشباح مدمره ما الذي حدث وماذا سيحدث فيها
هل ما زالت الجبهه الرئيسيه في الحرب
وماذا عن بدايات هجوم الربيع المضاد من
الجيش الاوكراني وما سيناريوهاتو هل سيكون
دفعه واحده ام على مراحل اتحدث حول هذا
الموضوع من كبير المحللين السياسيين جون
كابوليتش احييكم اينما كنتم من العربيه
انا منتهى الرمحي وهذا البعد الاخر
[موسيقى]
في جميع انحاء اوكرانيا قضى عشرات الالاف
من الرجال والنساء الشتاء في التدريب بهدف
استعاده اراض غزتها روسيا منذ الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير عام 2022 او حتى منذ
عام 2014 عندما ضمت شبه جزيره القرب في
الاثناء تفرض كييف السريه على حجم الضحايا
الذي تكبدته قواتها لكن التسريبات تقدر
العدد بحوالي 100000 بنسبه اقليه من
القتلى واغلبيه من الجرحى لكنهم غير
قادرين على حمل السلاح مره اخرى
ويقول المحلل العسكري اوليكسى من مؤسسه
رزمك ان نجاح في اي هجوم يتطلب ثلاثه
مهاجمين مقابل كل جندي مدافع وهذا يعني
انه يتعين على اوكرانيا اعداد مليون جندي
على الاقل
حتى الان تعد وزاره الداخليه تسعه الويه
انضم اليها حتى الان 40 الف متطوع اعمارهم
اقل من 35 عاما اما الجيش النظامي فقد شكل
20 لواء جديدا ضمن جيش ثان من خمسين الف
رجل ستكون مهمتهم السيطره على خط المواجهه
الذي يبلغ اكثر من الف كيلو متر اعدادا
للهجوم المضاد
وصرح ميخائيلو بودياك مستشار الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمير زيليسكي منذ الاسبوع
الاخير من مايو بان الهجوم المضاد بدا
اصلا قبل موعد تصريحه بايام مضيفا بان هذه
حرب عنيفه على طول حدود ممتده لالف وخمس
مئه كيلو متر ومنذ شهور يتزايد استهداف
الاجهزه اللوجسيه الروسيه في معظم المناطق
الخلفيه من الجبهه مستودعات الوقود
والذخيره وتقاطع السكك الحديديه والبنيه
التحتيه للاتصالات ومراكز القياده او حتى
معسكرات الجنود بقذائف او صواريخ او
طائرات بدون طيار الاوكرانيه في الاراضي
المحتله ولكن ايضا على الاراضي الروسيه
ويعتبر المحللون العسكريون ان ما تقوم به
القوات الاوكرانيه يسمى التشكيل او ان
نمذجه وهو شرط اساسي لاي هجوم كبير والهدف
منه هو اضعاف العدو بحمله مدفعيه لتدمير
اجهزه الدعم الخاصه به او اجباره على
نقلها بعيدا عن الجبهه لتنفيذ ذلك يعتمد
الاوكرانيون على تسليح غربي لوحظت
استخداماته الاولى في لونسك وايضا
لاستهداف قاعده جويه قربى مريوطا سبتمبر
بن عامي 2022 شن الاوكرانيون هجومهم
المضاد في منطقه خار كيف دون حمله مدفعيه
مثل ما يلاحظ الان وراهنوا على السرعه
والرعب ورغم انه كان خيارا محفوفا
بالمخاطر الا انه كان رابحا ففي غضون
اسابيع قليله حررت قوتك 500 بلده واثنتي
عشره او اثنين عشره الف كيلو متر مربع من
اراضي اوكرانيا اسمحوا لي ان ارحب بكبير
المحللين السياسيين جون كافوليتش اهلا بك
معنا سيد كاظم اتش سيد كافوليتش كيف تقيم
ما جرى او ما يجري في بخموت حتى الان مع
تقارير سيطره قوات فاجنر عليها ثم ربما
عوده لاحقا للقوات الاوكرانيه او تسليمها
للجيش الروسي بما يعني ان كل ما يتعلق
بباخوت
انه صراع يثير الاهتمام قبل فتره اعلنت
قوه فاجنر سيطرتها على بخموت وقبلها كانت
اوكرانيا قد اعلنت استعاده جزء كبير منه
وقبل ذلك بشهور كنا ننتظر ان تحكم قوات
الاتحاد الروسي سيطرتها تماما عليها لكن
وقتها توغل الاوكرانيون ضد ما نصحتهم به
قياده حلف شمال الاطلس والبنتاجون وعموما
ايا كان الوضع هناك فانه من الصعب الجزم
بانهم تخلوا عن المدينه بصفه نهائيه هم
يناورون في القتال وحتى لو كلفهم ذلك
الكثير ويترجم تقدمهما السابق مع ان يصمود
والبطوله وحتى الان يكلف ذلك الكثير من
حياه الناس من الجانبين لكن الاوكرانيين
حقيقه لم يظهروا اي نوعا من التراجع وهو
ما يمكن ان يكون الرساله التي يبعثون بها
قبل الهجوم الموعود والذي بدا في اعتقد
اذا قارنا بتلك التي وقعت في خاركيف
وخرسون العام الماضي بماذا تختلفان عن
بعضهما البعض
كنت في خاركيف الرابع والعشرين من فبراير
العام الماضي عندما بدا القصف
كما تعلمون موقع مميز جدا مع محاذاتها
المباشره للحدود الروسيه كما انها ثاني
اهم مدن اوكرانيا وهي مقر لشركات كبيره في
ميدان البيكتاك ولجامعات كبرى تضم الكثير
من الشباب اليافعيين وصناعات عديده
لقد كان الاوكرانيون نشطين جدا جدا في
الذود عنها ومع انها وقتها لم يلجا
الاوكرانيون الى الكثير من القتال والبعض
قال انهم كانوا يناورون فيما قال اخرون
انهم تراجعوا فانني اعتقد ان التعامل
القوات الروسيه معها على مستوى استراتيجي
كان على اساس انها لم تكن ضروريه في تلك
الفتره مثل ما هي عليه الان
فيما يتعلق بخرسون لقد كانت على مستوى
مختلف تماما من حيث القيمه الاستراتيجيه
فهي تقع في قلب ما اصبح العالم يعرفه تحت
اسم جسر الاسد الذي يربط القرم بمناطق
اخرى مثل زابوريا
حاجه ماسه للاحتفاظ بها بما يدعو ايديهم
على كل بحر ازف وايضا السيطره على منطقه
شاسعه من الصناعات والزراعات لذلك فمن
المحتمل بل ويمكننا ان نتوقع جميعا بان
خرسون ستكون هدفا للقوات الاوكرانيه ومع
اننا لا نعلم حجم المجهود الذي ستبذله
هناك لكن اخذا بعين الاعتبار ما اظهروه
منذ العام الماضي يمكن القول ان الروس
سيواجهون تحديات هناك للاحتفاظ بسطرتهم
عليها
نعم ولكن قالت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
انها نجحت في تدريب جنود اوكرانيين على
استخدام تشالنجر 2 في شهر واحد فقط فيما
يؤكد الخبراء الاوروبيون ايضا ان هذا غير
ممكن في اقل من ثلاثه اشهر على الاقل كيف
تصف هذا او تفسر هذا
كلاهما على حق فكلما تعلق الامر بتحليل
يداء القوات الاوكرانيه فانه يتعين تعليق
العمل بالمنطق المتعارف عليه فمن توقع في
الرابع والعشرين من فبراير العام الماضي
عندما اقتحمت القوات الروسيه العاصمه
ان يتم طردها وبسرعه من قبل القوه
الاوكرانيه ثم اثر ذلك تحقيق مكاسب عبر
ارجاء بلادهم ما قالته وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه
وجنرالاتها منطقي من حيث الحاجه الى
امتلاك الخبرات لكن الجنود الاوكرانيين
يبداون التدريب وهم لهم معرفه به بنوع
السلاح وكيفيه استخدامه يعرفون كيف
يستخدمون دبابه او صاروخا وذلك ما يجعل من
مده التعلم اكثر ايضا هناك الطاقه التي
يمنحها دافع الرغبه في التعلم ولذلك كانت
تلقي المعلومات اسهل الظروف حكمت على
الاوكرانيين بسرعه مثل ما كان الامر يتعلق
باي تلميذ مجتهد في المدرسه واي تكنولوجيا
يتم تقديمها لهم سيجلبون اليها شغفهم
ومعارفهم السابقه سواء كانت من بريطانيا
والمانيا او فرنسا او الولايات المتحده او
بولندا
ويفاجئونهم بقدرتهم على سرعه امتلاك
القدرات سواء من حيث الحفاظ على العتاد او
المفاجاه في كيفيه استخدامه
لو تحدثنا عن الهجوم المضاد ما هو
السيناريو الاكثر تفضيلا جندي ضد جندي
دبابه مقابل دبابه
سؤالك يثير نقاشا لانه فيما يتعلق بالسلاح
او بالدول يعضاء الناتو والتي تزود
اوكرانيا بالعتاد فان الجنرالات يرغبون
بصفه عامه برؤيه قتال يرغبون في استخدام
التجهيزات التي جرائم فاق الكثير عليها من
اجل نقلها الى اوكرانيا الولايات المتحده
ام فقط ما لا يقل عن 900 مليار دولار في
موازنه دفاعيه سنويا هذا اكثر من عشره
اضعاف اجمالي ما ساهمت به كل الدول
الاعضاء الاخرى في الناتو مجتمعه هذا مبلغ
ضخم وخيالي لدى اوكرانيا هذا الكم من
الصواريخ والدبابات والتجهيزات وكل
المساهمين يرغبون برؤيتها وهي بصدد
الاستخدام هم يرغبون بان يثبتوا لدافع
الضرائب بان تمويل هذه التجهيزات كان
مبررا وكان استثمارا من اجل الامن القومي
ايضا هناك منافسه تجاريه امريكا مصدر كبير
للسلاح وكذلك روسيا فنحن بصدد حرب
بالوكاله وكبار مسلحيها سلاح
مصنعي هي يرغبون بهذا القتال بين افضل ما
انتجت التكنولوجيا العسكريه الغربيه
ومنافستها الروسيه ولذلك وردا على سؤالك
حول ماهيه المعركه المرتقبه فان من يقف
وراء التسليح يرغب برؤيه معركه تقوم على
الاقتراب والمواجهه المباشره نوعا ما قوات
تواجه قوات سلاح بسلاح دبابه بدبابه طائره
بطائره صاروخ بصاروخ او جندي بجندي لاننا
الان لدينا مسيرات وغيرها من التحديثات ما
يوفر فرصه لعرض هذه الانجازات لكن هناك
تحدي امام اوكرانيا والدول التي تسلحها
فهي لا ترغب برؤيه تغطيه مباشره للمعركه
على هواء الشاشات القنوات التلفزيونيه حتى
لا تكون هناك فرصه لمشاهده التدمير
اختراعاتهم بقوه السلاح الروسي
سنذهب الى فاصلا قصير نعود بعده لمتابعه
هذا الحوار قومانا
اهلا بك معنا من جديد سيد كاظم اتش البعض
يقول بان الهجوم البري التقليدي يتطلب
ثلاثه اضعاف عدد الجنود في الجيش
الاوكراني الحالي هناك والخبراء يقولون ان
مثل هذا النجوم سيتطلب مشاركه مليون جندي
على الاقل في حين ان العدد المتاح كما
اشرنا لمثل هذا الهجوم لا يتجاوز 60 الف
هل اوكرانيا لديها عدد كافي من الرجال لشن
مثل هذا الهجوم
بالاضافه لذلك يظهر مقطع فيديو نشر في
الثاني والعشرين من مارس على شبكات
التواصل الاجتماعي الروسيه قافله طويله من
دبابات التيف 54 وصممت والتيفت فايف ايضا
صممت في عقاب الحرب العالميه الثانيه في
طريقها الى اوكرانيا من الشرق الاقصى الا
يدل هذا على نفاد معدات الجيش الروسي
انهم متوترون اولا لان كل الدول التي لها
علاقه بهذا الصراع الروسي الاوكراني لها
اهتمام عميق بنوع السلاح الذي يملكه الطرف
الاخر من النزاع المانيا هي مثال جيد
فلديها كم كبير من دبابات وعمرها عشرون
ثلاثون عاما وقد اظهرت الصور وهم اظهروها
وهي في مستودعاتها لقد فككت كلها وتقول
المانيا لدينا المئات من هذه التجهيزات
لكن المشكله ان جزءا منها لا يعمل بالنسبه
الى روسيا فان الامر هو عكس ذلك روسيا
تحتفظ بكل شيء وحتى اوكرانيا لذلك يمكن
القول اننا راينا نفس الجيل من الدبابات
او جل التجهيزات لدى الطرفين الان سيبدا
الروس بادخال تجهيزاتهم الجديده الى
الميدان سواء الطائرات المقاتله او
الدبابات او انظمه الس الحديثه اما
الاوكرانيون فسيقومون بشيء نفسه لكن ما
يختلف هذا العام هو ان الامر سيتعلق بزبده
الزبده من احدث العتاد يشير الخبراء الى
ان هناك استحاله باتخاذ اجراء حاسم مع
القوات البريه يمكن تعويضها بهجوم مركز
وقوي للغايه على منطقه معينه وهي زبولوجيا
الى اي مدى توافق على ذلك ولن يكون لذلك
خطر او يكون ذلك اكثر خطوره خاصه انه كما
تعلم هناك منشات نوويه في هذه المنطقه وهي
من اكبر واخطر المنشات في العالم هذا
معروف
معروفه بكونها مقرا لاضخم المنشاه النوويه
في اوروبا وتم قصفها واستهدافها ثم
السيطره عليها من قبل قوات الاتحاد الروسي
في بدايه الاحداث العمل الماضي فان القلق
يساور الجميع بشانها بشان او بسبب احتمال
تسرب النووي كل ذلك لا يجعلني في نفس
الوقت اعتقد ان القوات الاوكرانيه ستركز
على منطقه محدده تعرفون ان هناك الكثير من
الحديث بشان الهجوم الاوكراني لكن تقديري
ان الامر لن يتعلق بهجوم اوكراني ولكن
بهجمات اوكرانيه سيهاجمون عده مناطق سواء
بكيفيه متزامنه اول واحده والاخرى زابوريا
مهمه نعم وسيكونون سعداء باستعادتها مع
منشاتها النبويه خاصه لكن ذلك سيحتوي على
مخاطره بان يتسبب بحادث نووي لن يخطط له
لاروس ولا الاوكرانيون ولكن
تطلق الصواريخ عليك ان تستعد لاحتمال ان
يصيب احدها منشاه لم تخطط لاصابتها حتى لو
كان لديك اكثر انظمه الاستهداف دقه
فالحوادث ممكنه والاخطاء ترتكب وتكنولوجيا
تتعطل لذلك اعتقد ان الاوكرانيين والروسيا
يكونون حاضرين فيما يتعلق
فعندما جد حديث تشيرنوبيل كان هناك عامل
وحيد لم يستطع اي احد
التحكم به بما فيهم الولايات المتحده وهو
الرياح فحتى في غياب القصد فان اثار
الحادث بلغت الكثير من الاتجاهات التي لم
تكن في الحسبان بسبب عدم القدره على
التحكم في سرعه الرياح واتجاهاتها وهذا قد
يحدث مع مولدات الطاقه النوويه في يمكن ان
يتضرر احد المفاعلات ومنه تتسرب الاشعاعات
وقد نشهد انفجارات النوويه ولا يمكنك ان
تعرفي وجهه الريح التي يمكن ان تكون
الاراضي الروسيه نفسها لذلك سيكون هناك
الكثير من الحذر بشانها
هل يؤدي استعاده اوكرانيا سيطره على
غالبيه اراضيها او تسليمها بهزيمتها
النهائيه في باخم هل سيؤدي الى مفاوضات
وهل يمكن القول ايضا ان بدء المفاوضات
مرهون باستفاد مخزون اي من طرفي الصراع هل
ستكون هناك مفاوضات في كل الاحوال
نعم انا على ثقه من ذلك وايماني لم يتغير
بان المفاوضات ستنطلق او سنبدا بتحسسها في
غضون نهايه هذا العام والاسباب وراء ذلك
كثيره من ضمنها الهجوم الاوكراني هذا الذي
بدا وايضا الانتخابات الامريكيه وايضا في
عدد اخر من الدول التي لها علاقه بالحرب
كما ان مخصصات اوكرانيا في الموازنه
الامريكيه لها دخل لا سيما مع بدء موسم
الموازنه ومناقشتها في المؤسسات الامريكيه
والتي تبلغ ذروتها في سبتمبر واكتوبر
عندما يتم الكشف عن الارقام لمناقشتها وفي
حاله اوكرانيا خصص الكونجرس عام 2022 ما
لا يقل عن 113.1
دولار اما اداره بايدن والبينتاغون فقد
خصص اقل من عشره هذا العام ولذلك من
الواضح انهما ينظران للكونغرس لضخ المزيد
ويمكن ان يكون 50 مليارا اضافيا واعتقد ان
الحاله الوحيده التي قد لا نشهد فيها
مفاوضات هي عندما تبلغ الدول الداعمه
لاوكرانيا
بانها ستستمر بتزويدها بمزيد من السلاح
والمال حتى ولو كان الوضع على حاله مثل ما
كان عليه في الثالث والعشرين من فبراير
2023 والذي كانت روسيا تسيطر فيه على جزء
من لوهانس ودومباس والقرم والتي تسيطر
عليها عمليا منذ 2014 فهل نستمر مع ذلك
بتحميل دافع الضرائب كل هذه الاموال من
دون نتيجه على الميدان وفي حاله الولايات
المتحده فان هذه الاموال لا تاتي من
المدخرات او من صناديق متخصصه وانما من
الاقتراض هنا امريكا يتم اقتراض كل دولار
لتمويل اوكرانيا
اين يمكن ان اتوقع ان تكون تلك المفاوضات
ومن سيقودها او من سيرعاها
انا على ثقه بانه في كل الاحوال ستكون
هناك مفاوضات وانا ايضا مستمر بالاقتناع
بان دول شرق اوسطيه على الارجح ستشرف
وتلعب دورا رئيسيا فيها مثل ما لعبت
السعوديه دورا في تبادل السجناء او تركيا
ناهيك انني ارجح ان تحتضنها انقره مثلا
خاصه ان تركيا هي من ترعى مبادره البحر
الاسود للحبوب كل ذلك يعزز قناعتي باننا
سنرى مفاوضات بنهايه العام وما اعلمه وهو
ينطوي على شيء من الرعب هو ان الرئيسيين
بوتيننسكي مقتنعان بان الحرب ستستمر الى
ان يتم حل مسالتين اثنتين
اولهما هو توقف الدول عن دعمهم بان هناك
دولا تدعم اوكرانيا ولكنها في نفس الوقت
تضخ الاموال في الاقتصاد الروسي مقابل
صادرات محدده وثانيا حتى يبلغ عدد القتلى
مستوى يتطلب توقف الحرب ومن المحتمل ان
يكون هناك رقم فيما غير رئيسيين زيلينسكي
وبوتين 50 الف ومليون قتيل نحن لا نعرف
هذا الرقم لكن عندما يبلغ احدهما هذا
الرقم ساعتها سنرى الحرب تتوقف
اتصالات بين الطرفين هل هناك نوع من
المناقشات
نعم كانت هناك اتصالات منذ اليوم الاول
للحرب وما زال التواصل مستمرا الاستخبارات
والدوائر العسكريه ووزارات الخارجيه
واطراف ثالثه كلها ضالعه في الاتصال ايضا
مسؤولون سابقون هناك اتصالات يوميه وفي
بعض الاحيان عبر وساطات من اطراف ثالثه
كانت هناك دوما مناقشات واحد علاماتها
تبادل والسجناء والذي لا يحدث من فراغ
والذي لعبت فيه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
دور الرئيسي لانجاحه نعم كانت هناك
مناقشات وستستمر وهي احد اسباب استمرار
الرحلات الجويه من اسطنبول الى موسكو عبر
الخطوط التركيه التي تسير ما لا يقل عن
اربع رحلات يوميه بسبب ان هناك اطراف تقوم
بالرحله ذهابا وعوده يوميا بين موسكو كييف
هو الشارلين باكن
نعلم انه كانت هناك امال بل كان هناك
تقارير تشير الى ان هذا العام سيكون عام
المفاوضات بين الروس والاوكرانيين الان
وصلنا الى منتصف هذا العام والمؤشرات تؤكد
عكس ذلك متى يمكن ان نرى مفاوضات هل سيحدث
ذلك يوما ما
اتوقع لذلك ان يبدا في الحدوث انطلاقا من
سبتمبر والذي ستكون فيه صوره اوضح بما
يجعلنا نتوقع ما سيحدث بين سبتمبر وديسمبر
ورجح ان يكون الهجوم الاوكرانيين ناجحا في
بعض المناطق وفشلا في اخرى ولن يكون لذلك
علاقه بكفاءه الاوكرانيين او الروس وانما
بحجم الاشخاص الذين سيمكن للاتحاد الروسي
تجنيدهم ضمن قواته وحجم العتاد الذي سيكون
بحوزتها اذا قرر المسؤولون استخدامه ومن
الجانب الاوكراني نعم لديهم قوه ملتزمه
ولكنها ليست بالحجم الملائم كما لديهم
تجهيزات ولكن هناك نوع من الحدود له فقد
دابوا خلال الشهرين الماضيين على تكرار
انهم يحتكمون على 98% مما يحتاجون لبدء
هجومهم لكن على صعيدا اخر راينا الرئيسكي
يزور القاده الاوروبيين لتقليص حجم
توقعاتهم من اله
لماذا يبادر زيلينسكي الى تقليص حجم
الانتصارات بدلا من توسيعها للحصول على
مساعدات ودعم اكثر اليس هناك تناقض في هذه
المساله
هم يعرفون انه اذا كانت انتظاراتهم عاليه
وان الاوكرانيين لا يؤدون بشكل قوي او في
حال فشل محاوله طرد الروس من بعض المناطق
من دون ان يتم ذلك فساعتها سيبدا عدد كبير
من الدول في القول لهم حسنا لقد بذلتم
جهدا كبيرا ولكن ربما بكيفيه مهينه وبشعه
سيبلغونهم انه ينبغي البدء بمفاوضات ربما
لن تنتهي بالروس وهم ينسحبون تماما من
القرم او الدومباس على الاقل بعد الوقت
سيكون هناك صيف قاس جدا على الاوكرانيين
ومن الجانب الروسي لن يكون امامهم الكثير
من الاريحيه والمرونه بحيث سيتعلق بمدى
قدرتهم على تحمل الالم بسبب طبيعه الحكومه
هناك لذلك وللاسف سيكون الضغط على
الاوكرانيين من اجل ان يبلو البلاء الحسن
وان يبذلوا قصار الجهد وان يكون ذلك برؤيه
واضحه ثم بعد ذلك التفاوض على شيء ما حتى
مع علمهم بان ما قد يحصلون عليه سيكون
مؤقتا فقط مثل ما صرح بذلك الرئيس ديال
انسكي على الاقل حتى نرى قوات روسيا تخرج
من كل اوكرانيا ونعود هنا بعد ثلاثه او
اربع سنوات لانهم قد يكررون ذلك قد يكون
ذلك صحيحا ولكن هناك حدود تفريدها حجم
الاموال وحجم الاقتراض وايضا حجم الصبر
الذي يقع على كاهل داعمي اوكرانيا
شكرا جزيلا لك على مشاركتك معنا والى هنا
انتهت هذه الحلقه من البعد الاخر يمكنكم
دائما متابعتنا على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تويتر فيسبوك ويوتيوب كما
يمكنكم الاستماع الى حلقتنا على العربيه
بودكاست ومشاهدتها على شاهد الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]